the june european council is expected to
focus on four key priorities migration
is the first one the second key priority
security and defense in june the leaders
who review the progress achieved on
making the cooperation stronger on
external security as well as defense an
equally important objective as that of
jobs growth and competitiveness default
priority will focus on external
relations especially an irrelevant
political developments ahead of the
meeting we considered them to be
fundamental for a stronger better and
united future of europe france also kept
us informed on the follow-up that is
needed on the white paper on the future
of the European Union this is a highly
important process and successful
completion will result in a stronger
European Union thereby securing European
peace and prosperity for future
generations guaranteeing the future of
European Union depends on our ability to
move closer to our citizens but a
aligned us priorities to reflect better
our citizens aspirations I think I
control a number of conclusions after
the discussion we've had on the basis of
my reports on the state of play with the
law mechanism with Poland broad
agreement around the table that the rule
of law is a common interest and a common
responsibility I believe solutions can
be found and I have the impression that
the poorest government is now open for a
dialogue about this it is very clear it
is very clear that the issue the rule of
law the separation of powers is
something that all Member States feel
strongly about and that gives me the
possibility to try and show that we have
no misunderstandings and we have no
developments that go in a direction that
would not be in line with the necessity
to have a separation of powers and a
full respect of the rule of law